it's a little teenager so you know my
thing is just I gotta stay up till 12:00
sweating making sure they're kind of how
much right it's hard to believe Jada and
Will Smith's kids are still teenagers 17
year-old Jaden and fifteen-year-old
Willow are becoming huge stars in their
own right do they run all of their
career moves and yeah in a minute he'll
be a full-fledged adult and he'll be
like I don't have to come to you but
Willy I think we've been in wonderful
partnership with our kids and there's no
more dictating no you're gonna do it
this way I did that with two you know we
adopted a nephew and I have my
goddaughter and that didn't go well
it just didn't I mean it's fine now
they're adults and they got past their
difficulties but I definitely learned
from them to do it a different way
with Jaden and Willow it's really worked
well and it's really just about being a
partnership with what they want to do
and who they want to be and will and I
really had to break what we wanted them
to be big time Jada opened up about her
family to et at CinemaCon alongside the
cast of her upcoming comedy bad moms
we'll just won the MTV generation award
he joked about being old I think it's
just you know happiness to be honest I
mean I'm I've gotten so if I feel more
of myself and more clear more happy now
at 44 then I've ever felt I feel like
I'm beginning a whole new part of my
life and especially now that the kids
are doing